um I was going to
say fago is very much a thing that I
only knew about because of y'all like my
whole life I didn't know fago was a real
thing I always thought it was just your
guys's drink right didn't know it was a
thing I mean later on I I found out like
when I grew up and like you know certain
liquor stores would carry like exotic
snacks and West CO they have and then we
go to Detroit and any liquor store you
walk into there's like 50 flavors it's
pretty crazy yeah I love I mean did they
ever give you guys a piece of the
company they don't [__] with us that's
insane let me tell you something the
only thing they ever did for us yeah
right was give us a fagel machine in our
office
okay I'm going tell you something else
that's [__] crazy here's why they did
it right not because you guys are oh
your ICP um you know oh dope you know
it's cuz all they know is we're probably
their biggest customer cuz you guys so
all the who else buys more Fel what like
we do other than me maybe grocery dep
grocery departments but we're right in
there and they probably put fago
machines in the grocery departments all
the time too they just think we're one
of them they don't [__] know so when
you guys were launching not did they're
massive either right in Detroit Detroit
thing we are obviously helping these
[__] massively so when you guys
are you guys are launching all these two
lers into the crowd you're and try to
talk to him we have an attorney talk to
him like look man let's do something you
know like like just put out like a a
clown Cola or something a special let's
do a special cover for people that want
it [__] you know what I'm saying
I'm not asking you to put it in grocery
stores we'll buy them yeah but let's
work together so they never even gave
you guys show would even let us use
their [__] name in a in a um isn't
that ridiculous what I'm saying we got
to throw a [__] bomb in that
place
allegedly Alle no that is crazy cuz I
don't think I think why don't they work
with us I think the [__] you're the
yummy [__] fangos I've thrown and
sold what the [__] over 30 years they
better work with us and suck my dick
from the back [__] from the back from
the back from the back backwards twice
yeah yeah that's crazy so you guys were
buying all those TW lers they weren't
giving them to you come on wow bro we're
getting them whatever the charging you
know I always wondered right when you
guys like would would map out your tours
you have to have semis keep coming I was
I was I was just curious like on tour
you know you guys map out your tours is
there like a like the venue knows like
hey look man at the end of this show you
better have a cleanup crew cuz it's
going to be sticky of course they know
cuz you guys were launching
man it used to be wild I remember listen
to this we did back when all we had was
Detroit M we were we had not popped
anywhere we [__] ran Detroit though
including Toledo which is like an hour
right you know what I mean from Detroit
so um this too radio station is doing a
festival this is like [__]
94 they're doing a festival but we're
this massive local thing right so they
put us on this festival with uh Coolio
Outcast
um uh I don't remember right now too
short Too Short Too Short you know what
I mean and we're on there and we got
Fel half them fans you know what I mean
aren't jug you know what I mean but
there was a lot of [__] jug in there
you know and it was hype but Outcast was
like what the [__] you got fagel all
over our [__] turn tables you know
what I mean you know what I'm saying
they were like yo I feel him though no
we had to pay him who the [__] are these
guys throwing soda dressed like clowns
what is going on in [__] Toledo
straight up they surrounded us I'm not
going to lie so Out cast they got mad so
you guys had they walked up on us you
know with a message one dude could have
said I but they sent 15 to say hey you
guys got to pay for these turntables huh
you guys bought new turntables yeah we
had to buy new new equipment for him you
know what I mean it's a right thing to
do yeah of course what's the best flavor
of fago allegedly that's what I'm saying
one guy could have sent that said that
no for sure you know what I'm saying but
what's your favorite flavor of Foo uh
and this is assuming that they suck your
dick from the back and apologize um I
like grape grape that's pretty basic
what was the one that we had that was
like blue I know I didn't like Blue Mist
no Blue Mist no bro my favorite favorite
is um that I think his genius is is
called firework which that's the one
it's like a Bomb Pop bomb pop that
shit's fire you know how that became a
pop fagel ran a contest think of a
flavor you know what I'm saying somebody
sent that in that's a dope [__] idea
a Bomb Pop and add some [__] seler to
or whatever it we were in Detroit and
like I remember we probably bought like
nine bottles of Foo just to try we're
like bro we're never like we're this is
crazy we never seen so many random
flavors of soda and like all the rappers
are like you got to try this one cream
Peach they got Moon Mist Red Rock and Ry
you know um they got rock and Ry Moon
Mist was good well rock rock and Ry is
Dr Pepper okay Moon mist is is um it's
Mountain yeah yeah you know what I'm
saying no maybe it wasn't Moon Mist I'm
thinking of the blue one yeah the one he
said